look at the state of this garage
every car is well it's as if they've
been
blown up uh the huge big blocks of flats
that are behind it every single window
is out there's huge big holes as you go
up that that um that apartment every
single floor has got a hole
punched out of it look you can see
people up there i don't know whether you
can
make them out because we're shooting
against of the sun
but you can see people are in there and
these buildings are extremely fragile
right now they're very
insecure they're very we've been seeing
them full bits of building and
and masonry fall down all the time so
it's it's a very very still a very very
dangerous situation we're also very
close
i mean this is this scene is replicated
over
many many miles it's very difficult to
estimate just how
widespread the damage is but we've gone
through
many many streets and each one of them
is um is pretty much reduced
to rubble or much of of the buildings
that produce model now
you can see that we're in the middle of
a highway but i'm going to try and
get across just to show you look at the
look how this huge big warehouse which
is
has been um half of it is still
standing a lot of it including the goods
inside
are if we cross now um including the
goods inside have been
blown away blown away you i don't know
whether you can make out but there's
still
a little bit of smoke very much in the
distance
and there's been a helicopter that's a
fire still raging there there's been a
helicopter
and fire engines and ambulances going up
and down here for
the best part of well the past past hour
that we've been here
dumping huge buckets of water on
the flames it's gone a little bit quiet
um typically just as
as you came to us um luckily that means
you can hear me
but i mean this devastation goes on for
ages and ages and remember this is a
country
that was finding it was buckling under
the economic pressure
anyway from years and years of
corruption it didn't it had electricity
cuts hardly any
electricity um you know standard
electricity during the day
you couldn't find and buy ordinary items
like
toothpaste and soap the economy was
pretty much devastated anyway and this
well this will have flattened it people
won't be able to come back from this
many people just simply won't be able to
come back to it and remember
we're still in the middle of a global
pandemic where they have
hundreds of people who who they're
trying to treat for a deadly
disease so the the creaking medical
infrastructure was already
um under severe strain last night they
just couldn't cope this morning
they just can't cope they're talking
about um
dealing with people in the car parks and
one doctor
um talking to us called it apocalyptic
so
they're going to find it very difficult
to get back for this and and
there's still such a huge amount of
destruction
and well they've got to somehow get
themselves together
have a look at this car just one last
shot before you go
this is this this scene there are
hundreds thousands of cars all over the
place look
someone who's just driving along the
highway
the the um air pillows have
have inflated because they were going at
such a i think
even more how have you been coping can
you speak any english
no english that's a shame let's ask this
man if he if he do you speak english
yeah tell me where were you when it
happened and and how are you feeling
about all of this this morning
it is upsetting as we all know
devastating
yes especially the the situation we are
cutting through
for the last one year
hopefully it will be the end of our
miseries
i hope so god bless all the people we
lost
i live around 13 kilometers from here
at the mountains and
it was very loud very loud
well thank you very much for talking to
us and very best of luck i mean an
absolutely devastating
devastating scene you too for so many
people
here today and the the rest of the day
the next few days
are going to be similarly heartbreaking
for so many people